Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten. Mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff und ich begrüße alle zur 100. Folge von Raumzeit,
gar nicht so lange gedauert,
äh muss man sich erstmal ranpirschen. Die äh erste Sendung von Raumzeit ist schon eine Weile her. Das ist Ende 2010 gewesen. Jetzt haben wir Anfang zwanzig zweiundzwanzig, also,
na ja
mehr als elf Jahre und ich dachte mir so hm zur 100 könnte ich doch mal ein Thema nehmen, was vielleicht sonst nicht so auf der Agenda gewesen wäre und irgendwie gut zum Podcast passt.
Und die Wahl fiel auf Raumzeit. Warum nicht mal in Raumzeit auch mal über die Raumzeit reden, beziehungsweise
kosmischen Angelegenheiten, die ich am Anfang immer so andeute äh auch nochmal ein bisschen mit Leben füllen,
mal so schauen was eigentlich unser Verständnis vom Universum derzeit so,
ist. Und dafür bin ich nach Heidelberg gefahren und begrüße meine,
heute nämlich Lavinia Heisenberg. Schönen guten Tag.
Hallo und guten Tag.
Ja, herzlich willkommen bei äh Raumzeit. Navinia, du bist ähm,
Physikerin, theoretische Physikerin, Professorin auch an der ETH in Zürich,
sitzen wir jetzt gerade nicht in Zürich, warum sitzen wir jetzt in Heidelberg?
Ja, also ich bin jetzt seit äh November letzten Jahres ähm Professorin hier an der Uni Heidelberg.
Ich habe noch eine Gruppe in Zürich und deswegen habe ich noch eine Affiliate an der ETH. Und pendele so bisschen hin und her.
Okay. Und ähm ja warum fiel die Wahl auf Heidelberg dann? Mal was anderes ausprobieren.
Ähm ja also in der Akademie ist leider nicht so, dass man irgendwie frei den den Ort so ähm wählen kann. Also man bewirbt sich halt überall und ähm,
Glück und ähm konnte dann nach Heidelberg kommen. Also nach einem ähm Auswahlverfahren äh habe ich dann die die Stelle hier bekommen,
ist eine permanente Prüfstelle ähm und davor hatte ich nur begrenzte halt äh Stellen.
Auch allgemein Physik oder ist das nochmal ein bisschen genauer eingegrenzt?
Also allgemein in in natürlich in der Physik, aber auch allgemein in der Akademie ist es so, dass man äh,
keine Ahnung, dass man halt alle zwei, drei Jahre den Wohnort wechseln muss. Ein Postdock äh stelle hier, ein Postdock stelle dort und ähm genau.
Schicksal ist das.
Genau.
Aber man kommt schön rum und wir haben's auch sehr schön hier, wenn ich hier rausschaue, dann kann ich nur sagen, das war eine gute Wahl. Also hier blühen die Kirschbäume und es überhaupt alles ganz romantisch sowieso in Heidelberg weiß man ja.
Einem Blick auf ein Schloss äh vom Garten aus, ja ist nicht schlecht.
Schlechter laufen können, ne? Ja. Ja, vielleicht mal so ein bisschen zu deiner äh Hysterie. Wie bist du denn äh zum zu Wissenschaft gekommen? Was was äh was hat dich da äh gereizt? Wie früh fing das an?
Also ich würde schon sagen, seit meiner Kindheit ähm ich denke schon, dass ich halt sehr, sehr neugierig war und immer erfahren wollte oder wissen wollte, wie gewisse Dinge funktionieren.
Und ähm warum die Naturphänomene halt so funktionieren, wie sie funktionieren. Also es ging immer um diese Warum-Frage und das hat mich dann schon Stück für Stück da in Richtung Physik gebracht und ähm ich wollte auch Astronautin werden seit meiner Kindheit,
und ähm und deswegen bin ich irgendwie von Raum und Zeit äh nicht so weggekommen.
Was bestimmt der totale Terror für deine Eltern oder? Wolltest immer alles wissen und keiner konnte die richtigen Antworten geben.
Genau.
Ähm du bist ja ursprünglich aus der Schweiz, oder? Also oder wo bist du großgeworden?
Ähm ich würde sagen eher aus aus Deutschland, aber ich habe schon äh äh,
sehr sehr lange Zeit in der Schweiz äh verbracht. Deswegen ähm kriege ich diese Frage sehr oft gefragt. Ähm ich habe halt äh eine lange Zeit meines äh meine Karriere dort verbracht,
aber ja ursprünglich komme ich aus Deutschland.
Und bist du dann gleich mit Physik eingestiegen.
Genau, ich habe hier in Heidelberg Physik studiert. Mhm. Das Physikstudium äh abgeschlossen. Damals hatten wir noch nicht so dieses äh Bachelor und Mastersystem und habe dann direkt mein Diplom hier gemacht.
Und dann ging es dann Richtung nach Genf mit meiner Doktorarbeit.
Genau und ähm noch ein paar andere Stellen als als Prostorandin und irgendwann war ich dann an der ETH als als Assistentenprofessorin.
Mhm. Worum ging die Doktorarbeit?
Doktorarbeit ging um die ähm Schwerkraft und zwar um die massive Schwerkraft. Also wenn man,
nehmen würde, dass das Teilchen, was die Schwerkraft beschreibt, nicht masselos ist, sondern dass da,
kleine, aber nicht verschwindende Masse vorhanden ist.
Und ich habe dann äh von dieser Theorie sowohl dessen theoretische, als auch äh sozusagen äh phänomenoische Konsequenzen halt äh erarbeitet.
Jetzt ist es aber so, bei den Physikern so habe ich immer den Eindruck so zwischen den Experimentalphysikern und den Theoretikern da,
gibt's irgendwie, ich würde nicht sagen, Graben dazwischen, aber die sind irgendwie relativ klar äh definiert. Warum war das für dich von vornherein oder vielleicht war's ja auch gar nicht so, aber inwiefern hat es dich mehr in die theoretische Seite verschlagen, was,
Was geht da so in einem vor für dass man zu so einer Entscheidung kommt.
Also ich denke mal ähm ich habe so verschiedene Sachen ausprobiert und das sollte man ja auch äh im Studium und ich habe zum Beispiel meine Masterarbeit ähm über die Simulation gemacht,
Das war dann halt sehr sehr nomerierig
ich habe irgendwie ein Jahr lang rumprogrammiert und davon waren's irgendwie mehr als sechs Monate, dann halt die Buggy und ähm das hat mich nicht so gereizt und ähm da wurde mir immer mehr klar, dass ich in Richtung Theorie gehen will.
Aber ich denke durch meinen Wunsch Astronauten zu werden, habe ich immer so diesen äh ja diesen Kontakt gehabt ähm zu Beobachtungen, zu Praxis,
Ich wollte nicht einfach nur eine noch eine so ein zusätzliches theoretisches Modell aufbauen, sondern auch,
mich mit den Fragen irgendwie auseinandersetze? Wie kann man überhaupt dann so ein Modell testen und welche Beobachtungen kann man wie verwenden und ähm habe dann auch zum Teil halt selber diese Daten genommen und sie bewertet und,
habe gezielte Kollaboratoren ausgesucht, mit denen ich dann halt in diese Richtungen halt gehen konnte.
Und der Astronautentraum ist jetzt schon ausgeträumt, oder? Ist das doch eine Option?
Glaub der stirbt zuletzt.
Okay. Ja ähm jetzt
habe ich ja schon äh im Prinzip alles äh verraten. Wir wollen so ein bisschen mal um die Raumzeit herum äh reden. Das ist ja nur ein Aspekt ähm des ganzen kosmologischen Geschehens. Aber so dieses diese Verständnis der Welt, also ein
Bild zu entwickeln
wie alles zusammenhängt so, das ist ja denke ich auch so das primäre Ziel eigentlich der theoretischen Physik. Hier geht's ja wirklich ums große Ganze und irgendwie ein möglichst vollständiges Bild zu gewinnen. Und das gibt es nicht,
bisher.
Es ist schon sehr viel äh herausgefunden worden und trotzdem ist es so ein Feld, wo man das Gefühl hat, man kommt irgendwie nicht so richtig ans Ende, weil äh umso mehr man erforscht, umso mehr Fragen entstehen.
Trotzdem gab's ja einen,
na ja, nicht nur einen. Mehrere Wendepunkte so in der Physik und in der Wissenschaft als als solche, die man ganz gut an einzelnen Personen festmachen kann. Sicherlich, was so das Verständnis des Großen und Ganzen betrifft,
wo du da anfangen würdest, mir würde so Newton als Erster nennenswerter äh Punkt einfallen.
Also die erste wirklich konkrete äh nachvollziehbare Formelsammlung sozusagen Betrachtung von von,
Schwerkraft und wie alles zusammenhängt und damit ja auch das erste Mal so ein Bild, was auch über die Erde hinausging.
Also ich meine heutzutage verwenden wir immer noch die Nude,
Theorie. Ähm wenn es um äh,
Fragestellungen geht, die auf so relativ also so mittleren Skalen geschieht und,
Nicht so, dass man irgendwie ähm Theorie irgendwie ersetzt hätte oder sie nicht mehr gültig wäre oder sowas. Also klassische Mechanik, die ihr Leben wie hier jeden Tag auf der Erde.
Genau, auf der Erde funktioniert's super. Nur äh im Weltall halt nicht so richtig äh gut.
Genau, also wenn man dann irgendwann äh sehr hohe Geschwindigkeiten hat oder auch sehr hohe, sehr starke Schwerkraftpotenziale,
dann stößt in die täusche Theorie an dessen Grenzen und muss ersetzt werden,
und das ist genau das, was ein Stein gemacht hat, also ein Stein hat eine relativistische Version, den,
Theorie sozusagen entwickelt und das ist die allgemeine Relativitätstheorie.
Also man kann schon die New Tunnel Theorie verwenden, um zum Beispiel die Planetenbewegungen in unserem Sonnesystem zu berechnen,
Gesetze und so weiter ähm aber wenn man dann halt genaue ähm äh Berechnungen machen will, muss man irgendwann halt diese relativistische,
äh mit dazu nehmen,
Das ist hier zum Beispiel wichtig für unsere GPS-Geräte und wenn wir,
Ort viel genauer bestimmen wollen, dann muss man diese,
relativistische Korrekturen dazu nehmen und nicht nur einfach äh den Theorie sozusagen nehmen.
Ja sicherlich mit dieser Wissenschaftshistorie auch äh beschäftigt haben, muss man glaube ich zwangsläufig nicht wahr? Wenn man sich das äh theoretisch alles so reintun will, was würdest du sagen, war so der,
eigentliche die eigentliche Leistung von von Juten oder was war,
Was war sozusagen die Hürde, die dort genommen werden muss? Ich meine, mit so großen Entdeckungen ist ja immer das Problem, man weiß gar nicht, worüber man rüberspringen muss. So, man muss ja erstmal eine Intuition dafür bekommen, wo eigentlich das
Problem ist, wo warum man bisher einfach mit dem, was man sich bisher erdacht hat,
zu Recht nicht äh weiterkommt. Was äh denkst du war da die eigentliche Leistung von von Juten, damit er überhaupt in äh zu diesen Gesetzen kommen konnte?
Ja, ich denke wahrscheinlich war das schon so der erste Schritt ähm die Naturphänomene halt ähm,
Aktionen zu beschreiben oder dass man dann sagt ähm,
okay ähm das funktioniert so, weil da diese Kräfte äh gibt und die wirken auf einem und die Objekte werden dann auf die Art und Weise dann bewegt und das heißt, er er hat dann so systematisch ähm,
Das alles aufgrund von Aktionen halt beschrieben und das hat das dann zu einer ja richtigen Wissenschaft halt geführt.
Nur zu sagen, das könnte so und so funktionieren, was ja bisschen Richtung Philosophie ging davor, denke ich,
und dort hat man dann wirklich ähm gewisse Dinge beobachtet und gesehen, ja, wenn man da so ein Teilchen hat,
ein Objekt und man ähm lässt es in Ruhe, dann wird es mit derselben Geschwindigkeit für immer weiterlaufen.
Hat man daraus dann halt so eine Aktion gemacht.
Also meinst mathematisch beschrieben? Genau, also. Mhm.
Genau, also das war dann äh die mathematische Sprache genommen, um die Phänomene zu beschreiben anhand von Gesetzen.
Das hat so vorher noch nicht stattgefunden.
Auf die Art und Weise nicht, ja.
Was war denn dann die Art und Weise, die es jetzt anders gemacht hat als vorher.
Also diese mathematische Beschreibung. Ich denke, davor war's eher so ähm fast so ein bisschen philosophisch.
Gefühlt. Also es gab sozusagen keine. Also bis Newton gab es sozusagen überhaupt gar keine,
formale Definitionen, wo man mit Zahlen arbeiten konnte, sondern es gab immer nur Erwartungshaltung, aber ich meine, man war ja auch vorher schon in der Lage, Brücken zu bauen und äh große,
Gebäude schwierige, eigentlich ja schwierige mathematische Probleme wurden ja auch vorher in irgendeiner.
Ja ja, also Mathematik hat uns schon sehr lange begleitet. Aber ich denke ähm hat das dann halt oft diese allgemeine Fragestellungen, die eigentlich philosophisch waren, halt äh angewandt, aber mit Hilfe der Mathematik.
Mhm. Jetzt ist äh Einstein natürlich so,
größte Wendepunkt in dieser ganzen Frage. Da würde ich auch,
so mit einsteigen, was die eigentliche mentale Leistung jetzt war, dass Einstein,
diese Theorien entwickeln könnte. Man beschäftigt sich ja,
mit dieser Frage ist es nicht so, dass man sich die ganze Zeit äh denkt so, was muss ich anders denken als vorher, damit ich überhaupt mal zu einem Ergebnis komme, weil alles, was bisher gedacht wurde, führt mich in die Sackgasse, also was was geht da vor in dem Kopf?
Also ich glaube ich habe grundsätzlich so bisschen äh Schwierigkeiten mit dieser Art von Fragestellungen, weil äh es es klingt so, als ob da so ein ein konkreten äh Moment gegeben hat, ähm wo man dann halt eine,
momentane Leistung dazu irgendwie ordnen könnte. Er hat zehn Jahre lang dadran gearbeitet, oder? Und er hat an sehr, sehr verschiedenen Stellen,
ähm äh gewisse Dinge aufgegeben und und die dann durch neue Sichtweisen ersetzt.
Eine Sache war zum Beispiel, er hat dann halt aufgegeben, dass da so was wie eine Kraft äh vorhanden ist, also dass die Erde und der Mond sich halt anziehen, weil da halt so eine Kraft äh zwischen denen besteht, diese Schwerkraft, die,
sofort äh von einem Objekt, also von der Erde zum Mond propagiert.
Also unmittelbar.
Genau unmittelbar sofort, die immer da ist und ähm die mit unendlicher äh Geschwindigkeit sich äh von der Erde auf den Mond zum Beispiel propagieren würde.
Und das war so noch so ein bisschen das Bild von Newton, dass das einfach immer alles da ist, dass es immer.
Genau, das ist immer alles da ist und da ist so was wie eine absolute Zeit und,
so was wie ein absoluter Raum und zwischen den Objekten also gibt es dann halt Kräfte.
Aufeinander wirken.
Ähm für die Schwerkraft Einstein hat dann diese Sichtweise komplett aufgegeben und hat gesagt, da ist nicht so was wie eine Kraft, sondern er hat gesagt, ich nehme,
den Raum, diesen diesen dreidimensionalen Raum und verbinde ihn mit der Zeit,
habe ich meinen Raum Zeitkontinieur. Das sind Konzepte gewesen, die man sowieso schon kannte, eigentlich aus der Mathematik. Das ist nix anderes als Differentialgeometrie, was er gemacht hat,
aber äh vor seiner Zeit haben die Leute diese mathematische Sprache sozusagen nicht auf die Physik angewandt, also,
ja wie man sieht hatte im Grunde so wie Newton äh wieder versucht halt eine neue mathematische Sprache auf die Natur.
Aber was hat ihn denn eigentlich gestört am Status Quo? Also ich meine, wenn man über so was nachdenkt, dann muss man ja irgendwas lösen, was bisher dahin als ungelöst galt. Was was waren sozusagen die Herausforderungen, die es zu Umschiffen galt?
So wie heute wusste man schon, die Grenzen der New Turnschild Theorie. Wenn man zum Beispiel Geschwindigkeiten halt hatte, die die die sehr, sehr hoch waren,
oder die ähm.
Gravitationspotenziale, die die sehr stark waren. Dann äh haben diese Berechnungen, die man mit den Theorie gemacht hat, äh nicht übereinstimmt mit den zum Beispiel Planeten, Bewegungen und so weiter.
Also es äh es war einem schon klar, dass da irgendwas nicht ganz stimmt,
Hat dann versucht irgendwie anzunehmen, dass da irgendwelche dunkle Objekte vorhanden sind, vielleicht so zusätzliche,
Planeten, die die Planetenbewegung eventuell halt bisschen äh manipulieren würden, oder?
Hat dann halt gezielt nach diesen Dingern geschaut und aber nie gefunden. Das heißt äh damals war es schon auch den Leuten klar, dass die Theoriegrenzen hat,
dass sie nicht auf äh jedes System anwendbar ist, vor allem wenn das System halt hohe Geschwindigkeiten hat.
Betraf das nur den Merkur oder betraf das auch noch andere Planeten.
Die Merkur-Bewegung äh war so, dass äh das Hauptproblem.
Bei den anderen war hat's gepasst.
Genau, ja.
Okay. Das heißt, man hat man hat über Kur beobachtet, man hat's mit Juden ausgerechnet hm und dann fehlte ein bisschen.
Also wir reden ja nicht über große Abweichungen, sondern wir reden über geringe Abweichung.
Ja genau, also wie gesagt, man muss schon äh auf anderen äh auf andere Systeme gehen und um sehr viel größere ähm,
Unterschiede zu merken oder auch zum Beispiel bei wenn man jetzt auf ISS geht, was ja um um die Erde herum ziemlich schnell äh,
sich bewegt dann wühlen sich diese Effekte halt aufsammeln.
Und das ist dann zum Beispiel bei,
Bewegung genauso, dass wenn man das dann über Jahre halt mitverfolgt,
summieren sich diese diese Fehler.
Und das war das war sozusagen dann auch,
nicht der einzige, aber eine der Ansatzpunkte, wo einfach klar war, das Modell bis hierhin funktioniert so nicht und Annahmen, die bisher in dem alten Modell gemacht wurden, müssen unter Umständen komplett über Bord,
geschmissen werden, wie zum Beispiel diese Annahme, dass alles unmittelbar aufeinander wirkt.
Genau ja und man hatte auch ähm in der Zeit auch halt ähm Elektromagnetismus halt entdeckt und das ist halt eine komplett relativistische Theorie und,
sind dann andere grundsätzliche Natursymmetrien halt mit drin, anstatt Galiläen, Transformationen sind da die Lorenz Transformationen ähm.
Die die Hauptrolle übernehmen und ähm das war dann ja auch mit der Theorie nicht zu zu vereinbaren.
Was machen diese Transformation?
Also die können zum Beispiel von einem Initialsystem zum anderen Initialsystem äh zum Beispiel wenn man.
Mathematisches Modell erstmal oder.
Also das sind äh man könnte sagen, man hat zwei Beobachter, die ähm relativ zueinander sich bewegen.
Und ähm wenn man die Gesetze, die Einbeobachter beobachtet,
Gesetze des anderen Beobachters sozusagen umwandeln möchte, dann muss man diese Lorenz Transformationen anwenden.
Und das sind dann zwei Initialsysteme und zwischen denen kann man sozusagen hin und her springen und ähm und die Gesetze sollten sozusagen nicht davon abhängen, äh in welchem Initialsystem man drin ist.
Aber ein Schein hat auch ähm das aufgeben müssen und äh hat dann halt an den freien Fall gearbeitet, anstatt äh Initialsysteme.
Wenn du sagst, okay, relativistische äh.
Effekte, was muss man sich darunter vorstellen und was äh muss man verstehen, um das zu verstehen, was Einstein letzten Endes mit seinen Relativitätstheorien äh rausgehauen hat.
Ja, also eine der was was wir schon vorhin erwähnt haben, also da gibt's nicht so was wie ein absoluter Teil und absoluter Raum.
Die sind relativ sozusagen. Die hängen sehr stark davon ab, irgendwelche Bewegung der Beobachter sich befindet.
Der Beobachter halt ähm zum Beispiel durch Beschleunigungen und so durchgehen muss.
Also mit Beobachter meinen wir quasi so die Wahl eines beliebigen Ortes.
Genau, also.
Dem aus man alles andere betrachtet. Das ist der Beobachter.
Genau, der Beobachter, der könnte zum Beispiel hier in Ruhe sitzen und andere beobachtet, könnte dann irgendwie im Zug ähm sitzen, aber eine gewisse Geschwindigkeit haben.
Und ähm ein Beobachter könnte auf der Erde sein und an an ein anderer Beobachter irgendwo,
Weltraum in einem Raumschiff.
Ich denke, das fundamentale in der Einstein steht Theorie war wirklich diese Idee aufzugeben, dass so was wie eine,
Zeit vorhanden ist und sowas wie ein absoluter Raum vorhanden ist.
Und leider hat er dort nicht aufgehört. Der hat das nämlich noch noch abstrakter gemacht und um das mathematisch richtig formulieren zu können.
Er hat dann auch gesagt, dass wenn man jetzt Raum und Zeit zusammen tut in diesem Raum Zeitkontinuier, dann kann man.
Eigenschaften, dieses Raum-Zeit-Kontinuum nehmen, um die Schwerkraft zu beschreiben,
die Eigenschaft, die er gewählt hat, war die Krümmung.
Er hat dann die These aufgestellt und behauptet, dass die Schwerkraft gleich ist der Krümmung dieses Raumzeitkontinenums.
Das ist jetzt sehr abstrakt und sehr mathematisch, ähm aber im Grunde genau hat er wiederum diese differential geometrischen äh,
Ideen, aus der Mathematik dann auf die Schwerkraft angewandt.
Ich bin's nochmal so ein bisschen auf diese einzelnen Begriffe auch runterbrechen, damit das irgendwie auch äh klar wird. Ich meine, wenn du sagst, es gibt keinen absoluten Raum. So, da müssen wir vielleicht erstmal verstehen, okay was,
Was wäre denn ein absoluter Raum? Also wenn du sagst absoluter Raum, dann ist es die Vorstellung, dass quasi alles so ein dreidimensionales statisches,
Gebilde ist, in dem sich alles so bewegt, so wie unsere persönliche Wahrnehmung, unserer Umwelt ja normalerweise,
ja, wir beide sitzen jetzt hier in einem absoluten Raum, also,
in unserer Wahrnehmung, weil alles hat irgendwie genau einen Ort und und und alles verhält sich zueinander.
Identisch, ja? Das,
ist quasi das ist für uns der absolute Raum in dem alles gleich ist.
Man könnte sagen, man kann jetzt diesen diesen Raum hier nehmen, in dem wir hier sitzen und wir haben irgendwo an der Wand hoffentlich auch eine Uhr, die tickt. Ähm.
Haben wir nicht, aber wir denken uns jetzt mal gerade eine.
Genau ähm mit mit diese mit der Hilfe von dieser Uhr, die tickt.
Und mit diesen Linien, die ich jetzt hier durchgezogen habe, kann ich meinen Raum und meine Zeit äh beschreiben und dann kann ich auch die physikalischen Vorgänger hier auch beschreiben und das ist alles.
Zeit in dem absoluten Raum würde bedeuten die Uhrzeit, die von dieser Uhr angezeigt wird.
Gilt quasi für jedes für jeden Teil dieses Raums auf die gleiche Art und Weise. Und das ist ja so die Vorstellung, glaube ich, die man bis dahin immer gehabt hat.
Genau, also das heißt, wenn man am Ende des Universums gehen würde?
In die unendliche Ecke an das Universums. Ähm dort würde die Uhr genauso ticken und und es würde genauso funktionieren wie hier. Das wäre das das wäre dann sozusagen die Annahme von Newton.
Das heißt, sie würde überall auf dieselbe Art und Weise gelten und das ist ja dann genauso wie die Annahme mit der Gravitation bei Newton, dass dass immer alles überall sofort gilt und dass immer alles.
Auf die gleiche Art und Weise überall im Raum identisch ist für alle Beobachter.
Nur weiß man, dass das nicht so ist und mit welchem Gedankenmodell kann man sich das schnell klarmachen, dass das nicht so ist.
Also dieses Modell gilt äh ist vollkommen in Ordnung,
Wie ich gesagt habe, wenn man jetzt ähm ein ein ein Auto nimmt, das irgendwie sich bewegt innerhalb von diesem Raum, äh in dem wir uns befinden. Das Problem kommt nur, wenn man halt,
auf hohe Geschwindigkeiten geht.
Und ähm und das wiederum ist sehr schwierig für uns in unserem Alltag uns vorzustellen. Deswegen hat ja ein Stein halt all diese ganzen Gedankenexperimente gemacht. Und um das auch mit der sozusagen mit.
Mit Elektromagnetismus und also mit diesen Lorenz-Transformationen, die ich erwähnt habe, in Verbindung zu bringen, ähm war zum Beispiel eine ähm eine essenzielle Gedanke, dass da so was wie eine absolute Geschwindigkeit gibt,
ein ein Limit äh für für Geschwindigkeiten. Man kann nicht schneller sein als als das Licht. Und wenn man das dann annimmt,
und in die Theorie einbaut, dann sind es halt die Konsequenzen, dass die Zeit ähm anders verlaufen muss,
dass dieses Konzept von Raum Zeit sich ändert, wenn man, wenn man so was wie eine absolute absolutes Maximum für für die Geschwindigkeit hat.
Aber was ist der Beleg, also was ist wie wie ist er darauf gekommen woraus leitet man das ab, dass es eine maximale Geschwindigkeit geben muss.
Das ist eine Annahme, das ist eine These und das kommt vom Elektromagnetismus, also man man kann auch Experimente machen, zum Beispiel sie nehmen ein Licht und schicken ein Lichtsignal,
und setzen sich aber auf einem sehr schnellen ICE-Zug und dann, wenn sie an Newton glauben würden,
dann müsste jemand, der am Ende ähm,
äh des Tunnels irgendwie steht und diesen Zug äh beobachtet ähm dann müsst ihr diese Person annehmen, dass das Licht, was bei ihm ankommt ja Lichtgeschwindigkeit plus,
ihre und die Geschwindigkeit des Zuges haben müsste, oder? Und aber man misst das und man sieht, das das ist gar nicht so.
Das Licht ist immer noch genauso schnell wie wie ohne diese Geschwindigkeit.
Das heißt, es ist schon eine konkrete Beobachtung gewesen. Man hat das experimentell nachweisen können. Man hat einfach gemerkt, nur weil die Taschenlampe jetzt schneller äh durch
Gegend gefahren wird äh bewegt sich das Licht nicht schnell. Es kommt nicht früher an.
Genau, ja. Also mein Mann.
Waren denn das für Experimente bitte vor 120 Jahren oder so, mit denen man Lichtgeschwindigkeit so genau messen konnte?
Ich denke mal ähm wahrscheinlich äh diese ganzen äh Beobachtungen aus dem Sonnenfinsternis.
Dass man da ähm,
man man wusste sozusagen von von den nahen Sternen um uns herum, wie welchen Abstand sie haben,
Andere Messungen, die wir machen und da kann man da ja genau sehen, ähm wie wie lange sozusagen das Licht von diesem Stern braucht, um um bei uns anzukommen.
Aber ich kenne mich damit überhaupt nicht aus und ich ich bin da eher überfragt, welche konkrete.
Gehen wir da nicht weiter rein, aber ähm,
Es gibt die Feststellung das Licht überschreitet diese Geschwindigkeit nicht. Jetzt hätte man ja auch noch sagen können ja gut, das Licht äh ist vielleicht nicht so schnell, aber vielleicht ist ja irgendwas anderes schneller.
Ja, das das könnte schon sein, ja.
Das wusste man halt nicht. Ja. Also.
Ist eine Annahme, denn.
Eine Annahme. Okay, gut. Das heißt, wir haben.
Bis jetzt haben wir nix sozusagen beobachten können oder beobachtet, was irgendwie schneller wäre. Deswegen gilt diese Annahme immer noch.
Okay,
Versuche mich jetzt nur so ein bisschen in diese Denkweise reinzudenken, wie wie man denn überhaupt äh äh dahin gekommen ist und das ist halt jetzt sozusagen durch diese Entdeckung des Elektromagnetismus, also der der im Wesentlichen vor allem die Erkenntnis war,
dass es sich eben bei Magnetismus und Elektrizität um dieselbe Kraft,
handelt, dass sie äh direkt miteinander zu tun haben und letzten Endes dieselbe Kraft sind und dass eben Licht letzten Endes,
Elektromagnetismus ist und dass das ähm ja bestimmten Regeln äh genügt und unter anderem eben einfach eine maximale Geschwindigkeit hat und äh,
man ging schon damals davon aus, dass nichts schneller sein kann als Licht, weil er Licht so ein bisschen
Inbegriff eigentlich des Unendlichen für uns ist, also der unendlichen Geschwindigkeit, weil wir nehmen ja Licht immer wahr, als etwas, was auch irgendwie immer sofort da ist. Man
irgendwie jetzt hier auf die Berge und man sieht da oben äh die höchsten Bäume äh stehen und nichts würde einem das Gefühl geben, dass es dauert, bis diese Informationen zu uns kommt.
So wenn sie aber so ist es genau, wenn man ein bisschen weiter weggeht ähm,
und ähm sagen mal, früher hat man wahrscheinlich auch mit Feuer ähm quasi Lichtsignale geschickt und bis es einem anderen Dorf irgendwie angekommen ist, hat's ja auch irgendwie paar Sekunden gedauert.
Wie spielt das jetzt sozusagen in diesem absoluten Raum rein? Und der These, dass es diesen absoluten Raum nicht geben kann.
Was was spielt da für eine.
Na ja, jetzt wissen wir einfach, dass das etwas,
etwas dauert, also dass etwas eine maximale Geschwindigkeit hat, heißt ja dann im Umkehrschluss, nichts kann unendlich schnell sein,
wenn nichts unendlich schnell sein kann, dann kann es eben die Gravitation nicht nicht sein und das bedeutet ja auch, dass die Dinge nicht überall gleich gelten.
Also wenn man zum Beispiel irgendeine Änderung ähm irgendwo im Universum wenn es passiert wir stellen uns vor die Sonne auf einmal verschwindet aus irgendeinem Grund.
Dann würde das nicht instantan an uns weitergegeben diese Information, sondern die würde halt eine gewisse Zeit brauchen, um um bei uns anzukommen,
Das heißt, wenn es auch andere Phänomene geschehen, wenn, keine Ahnung, wen irgendwelche Dinge aufeinander knallen oder oder irgendwelche Ereignisse stattfinden, die würden diesen lokalen Raum Zeit um sich herum ändern?
Dessen Informationen würden wir halt ähm verspätet irgendwann dann auch mitbekommen.
Auf die Kernthese zurück. Es gibt keinen absoluten Raum und es gibt keine absolute Zeit. Wir hängt Zeit und Geschwindigkeit zusammen, was was für ein Bild von Zeit muss man haben.
Was ist Zeit.
Ja, das ist wiederum fast schon philosophisch. Also ähm für uns ist.
Muss man natürlich halt einfach von dem Beobachter ausgehen, was ist die Zeit und das ist ja die Zeit, die die Person,
wahrnimmt, indem es einen Maßstab nimmt, um zu sehen, wie gewisse Phänomene stattfinden, zum Beispiel ein Zerfall oder oder,
gewisse Dinge älter werden oder es könnte zum Beispiel einen einen Ticken einer Uhr sein oder es könnte eine ähm oder irgendwelche Phänomene zwischen den ähm,
wo die Teilchen irgendwelche ähm Zustände wechseln und wie wie benutzen das, um um sozusagen zu sagen, wie unsere Uhr tickt.
Aber als äh absolute Erklärung, was was Zeit ist, dass es dann schon schwierig. Also es gibt so ähm Ansätze, wo man versucht ähm,
Raum und Zeit aus äh aus der Quantenmechanik irgendwie ähm zu kriegen, einfach wo man dann sagt, da ist nicht so was wie Raum oder Zeit.
Da gibt's nur halt irgendwelche ähm Quanten ähm Zustände.
Diese Quantenzustände leben in einem Hibitraum und das wird alles nur um das sind alles nur mathematische Gegebenheiten sozusagen, aber diese Quanten,
Zustände haben irgendwelche Beziehungen oder Relationen und aus denen irgendwie entsteht dann Raum und Zeit und,
Das sind sehr, sehr abstrakte Ideen und ähm Ansätze sozusagen, wie man dann versucht, äh Raum und Zeit äh mit der mit mit Quantenmechanik irgendwie in Verbindung zu bringen.
Der Schritt geht mir vielleicht schon ein bisschen zu weit. Weil ich glaube viele scheitern so ein bisschen da dran äh Zeit eben nicht als etwas Absolutes,
anzusehen, weil wir's halt einfach anders,
weil wir's einfach anders äh erleben, weil wir eine andere Forschung davon haben. Zeit ist sozusagen das, was was alles ordnet. Die ganze Welt schreitet in einem fort auf einer Zeitachse nach vorne und
und so nehmen wir die Änderung wahr. Aber letzten Endes ist Zeit, eigentlich nichts anderes als,
unsere lokale Wahrnehmung von der Veränderung des Raums.
Genau ja die Veränderungen, die um uns herum passieren, genau.
Unendlich großen Bibliothekszimmer in dem wir hier sitzen halt auf diese Uhr starren dann ist halt irgendwie die Zeit an der Stelle wo die Uhr hängt und die Zeit die äh am Ende dieses
nicht unendlich großen Raums, aber dieser großen äh äh Raums äh ankommt sozusagen. Zwangsläufig mit einer Verzögerung
verbunden, weil wir diese Wahrnehmung der Änderung der Zeiger, die so langsam voranschreiten, später wahrnehmen
weil es ja nicht schneller sein kann als das Licht, weil es eben diese maximale Geschwindigkeit gibt und deswegen ist es eben,
nicht absolut, sondern es ist halt relativ relativ zu der Beobachtungsposition selbst. Das ist das, was Relativität letzten Endes ausdrückt. Das ist einfach die Welt,
anders ist, je nachdem, wo man sich befindet, relativ zu, wo sich alle anderen befinden. Genau. Kann man das so zusammenfassen?
Genau, also man man kann sozusagen ein ein Zeit und einen Raum für einen Beobachter hier definieren und einen Raum und Zeit dort,
aber die alle sind verknüpft. Also man kann das schon mathematisch berechnen, wenn wir diese Raumzeitzustände hier so haben,
und zwischen uns sagen wir, befinden sich diese Art von Materieformen, können wir genau berechnen, wie Raumzeit, sagen wir, am Ende dieses Raumes,
auszuschauen hat.
Also Raum und Zeit und diese Geschwindigkeit, dass die Geschwindigkeit konstant ist,
das war so im Prinzip die Essenz dieser speziellen Relativitätstheorie, also des ersten Traktats, was was Einstein rausgebracht hat
Das war aber damals, wenn ich das so richtig sehe, auch nur so was irgendwie veröffentlicht wurde und nicht automatisch zu irgendeiner äh Weltreaktion geführt hat.
Oder? So war das doch.
Ja, ich denke mal, als ähm Einstein damals seine Theorie entwickelt hat, ähm ja, waren viele schon skeptisch und ähm es gab ja auch keinen wirklichen Bedarf,
es gab schon so ein paar ähm Dinge, die man vielleicht nicht genau erklären konnte, wie wir erwähnt haben, zum Beispiel mit mit der Merkur-Bewegung.
Ähm aber es gab es war einfach nur eine so ein ja mathematische Vorstellung von dem oder? Es gab es es gab keinen richtigen Bedarf für seine Theorie.
Er hat's trotzdem weiter gemacht und er hat dann halt konkrete Voraussagen gemacht und man ist dann gegangen und hat diese Voraussagen gecheckt.
Und äh als man dann rausgefunden hat, oh das stimmt, ähm dann hat man halt angefangen ihn in ernste zu nehmen.
Das war jetzt schon diese äh Geschichte mit der Expedition zum Richtung Nordpol und der Beobachtung des Sterns
Aber das, nee, das bezog sich doch auf die allgemeine Relativitätstheorie. Also was hat denn diese spezielle Relativitätstheorie bewiesen?
Also die spezielle Relativitätstheorie, also.
Ich würde sagen in der Form die gab's ja schon irgendwie dank äh Lorenz und wir hatten ja schon die Lorenz Transformationen ähm,
Ich denke mal ähm durch die spezielle Relativitätstheorie hat er dann halt Elektromagnetismus äh in eine vollkommene Theorie ähm,
mathematisch halt darstellen können und beschreiben können. Und das hat halt davor gefehlt.
Man hatte zwar die Mixbegleichungen, ähm aber ein Stein hat sie dann in eine, in eine richtige Relativitätstheorie eingebraucht.
Gleichung ist das, was was den Elektromagnetismus.
Genau, was was das Phänomen von von Elektromagnetismus beschrieben hat. Und wenn man die spezielle Realitätstheorie nimmt und,
Bestimmte äh Voraussagen macht, wie zum Beispiel ähm diesen Fotoeffekt, was ja Einstein ja auch vorher gesagt hat und deswegen hat er auch einen Nobelpreis bekommen.
Für den Fotoelektrischen Effekt. Was beschreibt der fotoelektrische Effekt.
Genau, also das sind dann im im Grunde ähm sind es dann ähm also man man hat halt so ein so ein Modell, man man denkt dann.
Da ist dann halt unser Atom, das ist ja so was wie ein wie ein Kern und um diesen Kern herum bewegen sich die Elektronen und die können irgendwelche Energiezustände einnehmen.
Je nachdem auf welchen Energiezustand sie sind, mhm schicken sie gewisse Photonen heraus, also gewisses Licht und die kann man dann halt beobachten und im Grunde ging es darum, diese Möglichkeit diese Zustände zu beobachten.
Das heißt, er hat eigentlich auch schon im Kleinsten gearbeitet und gar nicht mal nur im im Größten. Ja. Obwohl letzten Endes die spezielle Relativitätstheorie versucht hat, eigentlich das Große zu fassen.
Genau, also die ähm die Verallgemeinerung sozusagen zu der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie die war dann natürlich schwierig, weil es halt auf äh,
Das Ganze ging also auf das größere, auf diese größeren Skalen und ähm dafür hat er dann halt zehn Jahre gebraucht,
der speziellen Realitätstheorie zu der Allgemeinen.
Mhm. Okay, dann gehen wir noch mal diesen Schritt. Also in diesen ganzen zehn Jahren war auch diese spezielle Relativitätstheorie,
keinen Weltenbewegendes,
Ding in dem Sinne. Also er hat so glaube ich als Person zwar sicherlich einen Namen äh gehabt, aber es war jetzt nicht so, dass schon die spezielle Relativitätstheorie allein die Dinge ins Wanken gebracht hat.
Ich finde, ich finde das jetzt nicht so sagen. Also ich bin kein keine ich bin keine Expertin, was die Geschichte angeht. Deswegen, ich glaube, ich bin da ein bisschen überfragt.
Ähm aber ich würde schon sagen, dass das alles ähm,
so Anfang 1900 Ingwers, ähm dass da schon viele Sachen passiert sind, viele in Bewegung gekommen ist und die spezielle Relativitätstheorie und dann,
Quantenmechanik und und daraus dann die Quantenfeldtheorie, also ähm da da ist schon viel passiert und ähm,
Und ich glaube nicht, dass man dann sagen könnte, ja es es fand irgendwie statt. Also für die Schwerkraft stimmt schon, dass da keinen wirklichen wirklichen Bedarf da war.
Aber ähm,
Ähm alles, was um uns herum geschah und und diese ganzen also die Teilchenphysik und und da hat man halt immer wieder neue neue Sachen dazu entdeckt. So man hat irgendwie gesehen, da gibt's sowas wie Photonen und Elektronen.
Und ähm und das ist genau diese dass diese Elektronen halt, wenn sie Zustände wechseln, halt Photonen schicken können,
sowas wie Neutrinus gibt und noch viele, viele andere Teilchen. Und Stück für Stück hat man dann ganz, ganz viel Wissen angesammelt.
Ich versuche jetzt auch nur zu verstehen, was jetzt sozusagen durch diese allgemeine Relativitätstheorie dazugekommen ist. Also was ist das das das inwiefern hat sich das Bild, das Gesamtbild, was aus seiner Arbeit hervorgegangen ist, jetzt noch
erweitert, was war was war jetzt das Problem, was er lösen wollte? Ich meine vorher die spezielle Relativitätstheorie liegt ja jetzt erstmal so ein bisschen so.
Das ist so Groundwork so. Okay, ich gehe davon aus, es gibt keinen absoluten Raum, es gibt keine absolute Zeit, alles ist irgendwie relativ zueinander. Lichtgeschwindigkeit ist absolut so, kann man sagen, ja okay, alles klar. Das Leben
äh geht jetzt äh weiter. Die allgemeine Relativitätstheorie bringt ja jetzt quasi die Gravitation überhaupt das erste Mal,
mit ins Spiel, weil man das.
Genau, er muss jetzt die Schwerkraft, mit diesen Ideen in im Anklang bringen, dass das.
Mhm. Das war sein Ziel.
Das das liegt halt begrenzt ist und ähm das gewisse Phänomene halt diese,
Lorenz Transformation folgen und ähm dass sowas wie absoluter Raum und Zeit nicht gibt. Das musste er ja jetzt mit mit der Schwerkraft in Verbindung bringen.
Aber das kann man ja nicht mit der Theorie.
Und da hat er dann zehn Jahre drüber nachgedacht.
Also genau, das heißt, der musste dann halt eine Theorie entwickeln, die genau mit diesen ganzen Beobachtungen.
Übereinstimmen würde oder halt zusammen Hand in Hand gehen konnte.
Dann schauen wir uns doch mal an, was jetzt sozusagen das Modell ist, was daraus herausgekommen ist aus dem ähm aus dieser Betrachtung.
Einstein ist das immer so ein bisschen so, man meint das immer so zu kennen und so ja allgemeine Relativitätstheorie, alles ist anders und jetzt gibt's halt irgendwie Raumzeit.
Aber da stecken ja eigentlich sehr viele Erkenntnisse gleichzeitig mit mit drin.
Was beschreibt die allgemeine Relativitätstheorie und welches Bild der Welt ist letzten Endes daraus entstanden.
Also daraus ist halt wie wie ich gesagt habe, das abstrakte Bild entstanden, dass die Schwerkraft ähm nix anderes als als die Krümmung des Raumzeits.
Das war seine Idee oder seine These, die er dann aufgestellt hat. Also er hat gesagt, da gibt's so was wie ein wie ein diesen diesen abstrakten Raum Zeit und,
Wenn man jetzt sich irgendwas äh irgendwie so einen flachen Raum Zeitkontinenum vorstellen würde, das ist komplett flach,
Das würde man mit einer Minkowski beschreiben,
ähm und jetzt tut man sowas wie einen massiven Objekt dadrauf, so wie zum Beispiel auch vom Trampolin oder.
Würde dieser dieser dieses flache Raum Zeit kontinuieren würde, dann gekrümmt werden? Wäre nicht mehr so flach.
Und und wenn man jetzt noch einen zusätzlichen Objekt dazu tut war seine Behauptung, dass die Schwerkraft ähm dadurch gespürt wird, dass diese andere große Objekt ja den Raum gekrönt hatte.
Dieser kleinere zweite Objekt fühlt dann diese Krümmung äh dieses Raumzeit-Kontinuums.
Dieses zweidimensionale Modell ist für uns glaube ich ganz gut,
Um das überhaupt erstmal überhaupt erstmal was greifbares zu haben, nicht so dieses dieses durchgebogene äh Trampolin. Trotzdem muss man das natürlich im Kopf schon dann aber auch auf einen dreidimensionalen Raum erweiter.
Vierdimensionalen Raum.
Letzten Endes einen vierdimensionalen Raum. Aber ich versuche gerade mal so ein bisschen die Brücke äh zu schlagen. Denn,
Die Kernaussage ist ja, dass die Zeit relativ ist und die Zeit drückt sich aus,
durch diese maximale Geschwindigkeit, in der eine Änderung kommuniziert werden kann. Das ist ja letzten Endes,
Licht oder irgendeine andere Strahlung, Licht ist ja nur ein Teil dieses Spektrums, den wir halt mit unseren Augen sehen können, aber der gesamte Elektromagnetismus ist ja quasi,
maximal mit dieser Geschwindigkeit unterwegs, auch ja nicht unbedingt immer in dieser Geschwindigkeit, aber eben nicht schneller als in dieser Geschwindigkeit. Das heißt, jede Änderung und damit eben unsere Vorstellung von Zeit, weil sich Dinge ändern
wird maximal mit dieser äh Geschwindigkeit,
kommuniziert. Wenn jetzt der Raum, in dem sich diese Strahlung ausbreitet, diese Kommunikation sich ausbreitet, gekrümmt wird, also in dem Fall.
Quasi.
Genau, ne, also also äh bleiben wir mal bei dem Trampolinbeispiel. Ich lege da jetzt so eine dicke, fette Stahlkugel rein, die dann äh das alles so nach unten zieht.
Dann bedeutet das ja, dass diese Kommunikation, die vorher eine gerade Linie beschrieben hat, jetzt durch diese Krümmung durchgehen muss,
und wieder nach oben und auf die andere Seite kommt und damit ihr einen längeren Weg beschreibt. Und wenn man nicht schneller sein kann,
die Lichtgeschwindigkeit einfach ein Maximum hat, dann dauert es halt entsprechend länger.
Das heißt, die Zeit dehnt sich aus mit dem Raum.
Also.
Ja, also man man könnte dann halt sagen, dadurch, dass dass das Licht, was geschickt wird, halt diese ähm wie haben sie sie genannt, ähm die Dellen, also diese diese Krümmungen.
Ja die Vertiefung, wer auch immer.
Genau ähm weil das Licht halt diese Vertiefungen spürt und nicht mehr auf einer geraden Linie.
Sich bewegt, das heißt das Licht selber wird gekrümmt und das war ja seine Vorhersage und man hat das dann halt in diesem Sonnenfinsternis auch.
Beobachtet und und dadurch wurde er halt äh von von einem Tag auf den nächsten super berühmt.
Ja, weil das das war ja im Prinzip die die Vorhersage. Ich versuche jetzt nur gerade mal so zu verstehen, was das bedeutet ein vierdimensionalen Raum zu haben, weil wir denken ja nicht so. Wir denken ja nicht in.
Das kann keiner. Also ich kann keinen vierdimensionalen Raum mir vorstellen. Das beruhigt mich jetzt. Ja, das kann keiner.
Auch nicht. Das beruhigt mich jetzt sehr. Ja. Aber trotzdem ist es so.
Aber genau, aber es ist halt eine mathematische, abstrakte mathematische Beschreibung. Und dieses zweidimensionale Bild soll uns ja nur helfen, um das zu verstehen, aber im Grund ist es nur ein ein ja mathematischer Hilfsmittel.
Diese Erklärung, dass die Gravitation letzten Endes nur eine Krümmung ist, also eher eine ein Abfallprodukt. Man geht einfach einen längeren Weg, weil der Raum, in dem man sich bewegt, ist halt verzerrt. Man bewegt sich nach wie vor genauso,
schnell oder kann zumindest nicht nicht nicht schneller gehen, nur weil der Raum sich auf einmal ausdehnt, kann ich ihn nicht schneller durchschreiten, also,
muss ich.
Da muss man vorsichtig sein mit solchen.
Vorsichtig mit den Aussagen. Ich lasse mich sofort korrigieren.
Also wenn wenn zum Beispiel das Universum, das tut es ja eigentlich, wenn es irgendwie sich beschleunigt, expandiert, dann kann man im Grunde schon äh äh auf auf andere.
Vielleicht das Universum erstmal raus, nur um erstmal zu verstehen, wie die Krümel sich, sagen wir mal, konkret jetzt in unserem Sonnensystem äh,
niederschlägt, weil die eigentliche Frage war ja immer so, okay warum dreht sich jetzt die Erde um die Sonne
so und das Bild war na ja klar wegen Schwerkraft.
So und das alte nytonische Bild ist, dass das eben so eine starre Verbindung ist, die unmittelbar ist und im Prinzip war ja ein äh Ansage so, ja nee ist nicht unmittelbar, das dauert irgendwie eine Weile.
Trotzdem war ja immer noch die Frage, okay, was ist denn dann diese Kraft, selbst wenn sie nicht unmittelbar ist, wodurch warum ziehen die sich äh eigentlich an?
Und letztlich ist ja die Raumkrümmung, die Erklärung,
Ja, sie ziehen sich nicht in dem Sinne an, sondern beide Objekte, sowohl die Sonne als auch die Erde im Kleinen.
Krummen diesen Raum, so dass die anderen Objekte sich zwangsläufig in diesem Raum anders bewegen müssen.
Genau, die die ziehen sich angezogen, weil da halt diese Vertiefungen im Raum entstehen.
Das heißt, die Erde dreht sich gar nicht um die Sonne, sondern sie schießt eigentlich die ganze Zeit geradeaus, weil was anderes kennt sie eigentlich gar nicht, nur,
der Raum nicht mehr geradeaus ist, sondern der Raum ist halt so um die Sonne herum gekrümmt, dass eben ja wir uns wie in so einer Badewanne äh oder eben in diesem Trampolin
glauben zwar immer geradeaus zu bewegen, aber bewegen uns quasi auf einer Kreisbahn geradeaus. Und das ist sozusagen der Ort, in dem sich alles abspielt,
Heißt aber auch, dass wenn jetzt wenn man bei dem Beispiel bleiben ähm die Sonne ist jetzt weg,
Ja, nicht nur, dass das für uns erst nach acht Minuten sichtbar wäre, weil eben das Licht so lange braucht, um zu uns zu kommen, heißt das, dass dann auch,
Dieser Krümmungseffekt 8 Minuten braucht, bis er bei uns ist.
Genau, also das heißt, eigentlich ähm müsste man dann äh anfangen zu sehen, nach acht Minuten, dass dass die diese diese die drei also diese Laufbahn von der Erde sich anfängt zu ändern.
Schlagartig dann oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Ich meine, wenn die Sonne nehmen wir an, sondern es ist einfach mal weg, so wie aufm Bildschirm einfach weggeklickt, jetzt gibt's irgendwie keine Sonne mehr.
Würden wir erst mal acht Minuten lang weiterhin auf unserer Umlaufbahn um diese Sonne weiter ziehen, weil,
Wir können das ja noch gar nicht mitbekommen haben, weil nichts kann schneller sein als das Licht, also kann auch diese Krümmung sich nicht schneller fortbewegen als das Licht.
Genau, also nach acht Minuten müssten wir dann von unserer äh von diesem Kreis abweichen und auf anfangen, gerade uns zu bewegen. Klar, da sind noch andere Planeten um uns herum, aber wenn wir wenn wir jetzt vorstellen, dass da nur die Sonne und die Erde wäre.
Würden im Prinzip alle ab dem Punkt, wo sie gerade sind, dann einfach wirklich geradeaus weiter schießen. Weil einfach ist ja nichts mehr da, worum man sich.
Mehr da, genau.
Wie kann man sich das jetzt vorstellen? Also was wirkt denn dann da auf den Raum?
Das ist das ist sehr philosophisch. Ich kann das nicht beantworten. Das wie gesagt, das ist eine.
So weit gereist.
Also äh ich es man soll das nicht so verstehen, als wäre da sowas wie ein Eter, so ein Ethamidum, das um uns herum gibt.
Trotzdem muss er da was wirken. Also irgendeine Wirkung gibt es ja, aber sonst würde sich ja der Raum nicht krummen. Und der krümmt sich.
Die Wirkung ist ja die Wirkung ist ja äh durch die Krümmung, aber so wie ich ihre Frage verstanden habe, ähm wollen sie die krümmung irgendwie,
besser vorstellen oder wenn sie jetzt auf einmal nicht da ist, warum spürst du sie nicht mehr?
Ich akzeptiere, dass die Krümmung jetzt da ist, aber ich würde jetzt gerne wissen, warum krümmt es sich? Wodurch krümt es sich? Und wir wissen, okay, es ist die Masse, die Masse, okay, so.
Masse und Energie, genau. Das ist ähm.
Laut Einstein das Gleiche.
Also Masse krümt dann die, diesen Raum Zeit und wenn wenn man diese Masse wegnimmt, dann ja, dann nimmt man noch die Krümmung weg.
Aber warum krümmt denn die Masse den Raum? Also es könnte dem Raum ja eigentlich auch völlig egal sein.
Das ist die die oder? Das ist die die Behauptung. Das ist eine Annahme.
Okay, ist eine Annahme und man kann sie man weiß, man weiß, dass es stimmt, man weiß, dass es so ist, weil wir es einfach die ganze Zeit nachrechnen können, alle.
Da wäre ich sogar vorsichtig, also ich ich würde jetzt nicht behaupten, man weiß, dass es so ist und dass es so stimmt,
Wie gesagt, es ist eine mathematische Beschreibung, die uns hilft, diese Phänomene zu beschreiben, aber man kann auch andere mathematische Beschreibungen finden, die genauso diese Phänomene beschreiben würden, aber wo vielleicht,
das Raum Zeitkontinenum nicht unbedingt gekrönt ist.
Okay, jetzt nochmal zurück zu dieser äh Fragestellung,
Die Sonne ist jetzt einfach da. Die Sonne hat viel Masse, heißt viele Atome, viel Protonen, Neuronen, paar Elektronen, andere Sachen vielleicht auch noch. Alles sehr dicht beisammen.
Immerhin ist ein großer Feuerball, da ist richtig was los und äh,
Die Sonne kämpft ja im Prinzip die ganze Zeit mit sich selber, nicht wahr? Sie stürzt die ganze Zeit in sich zusammen und explodiert immer so ein bisschen und drückt sich wieder nach außen, deswegen leuchtet sie und ist halt einfach äh da.
Der Raum, okay, wir haben jetzt,
Äther. Also nichts kein kein unsichtbares Gewebe, in dem sich irgendwas was irgendwie ein Trägermedium ist. Das war ja auch so eine alte Idee. Trotzdem irgendwas ist ja da,
Weil wenn diese Masse dadrauf wirkt.
Na ja, da muss ja auch irgendwas da sein, was was wirkt. Also ich versuche zu verstehen, was eigentlich den Raum als solchen ausmacht, wenn ich all die Materie wegnehme, was was bleibt über.
Dann bleibt einfach ähm ein leerer Raum. Also das ist dann diese dieser flache Raum, den wir uns ja am Anfang vorgestellt haben. Ist komplett flach,
Man hat äh überall Quadrate, diesen schönen Quadratisch. Hat man hingemalt und ähm.
Gut, aber das sind ja keine Quadrate, sondern.
Nix verzerrt, dass es dann komplett, genau.
Dieser flache Raum. Ich weiß schon, in welche Richtung ihre Bemühungen gehen, aber äh das wird nicht einfach sein, weil das wirklich äh,
eine abstrakte mathematische Idee ist und man darf das nicht so wortwörtlich nehmen, weil ähm wie wie wir es auch gezeigt haben. Man kann auch die allgemeine Relativitätstheorie,
immer noch mit geometrischen Eigenschaften des Raum, Zeitkontinums beschreiben, aber das muss nicht unbedingt mit der Krümmung sein,
Also ähm wenn man differentialgeometrimmt und sagen wir mal ähm sich anschaut, welche andere Eigenschaften können können noch die Raumzeit-Kontier haben,
Krümmung, das ist aber auch die Tusion und auch die nichtmetrik. Das sind also drei unterschiedliche Eigenschaften, mathematische Eigenschaften, die einen Raumzeit haben kann,
Wir haben auch gezeigt, dass man die allgemeine Relativitätstheorie nicht nur mit Hilfe der Krümmung beschreiben kann, sondern zum Beispiel mithilfe dieser nichtmetrik beschreiben kann,
Und da hat man dann nicht mehr diese Interpretation, dass das Raumzeit gekrümmt wäre und dass man deswegen die Schwerkraft äh spürt. Es gibt auch andere Interpretationen, wo man dann sagt, das hat nix mit der krümmung,
Raum Zeit zu tun, sondern dass es ein Teilchen. Das Eis äh die Erde.
Die Schwerkraft ist ein Teilchen. Da gibt's sowas wie wie bei den beim Licht ist ja die Photonen, die die äh wechselwirken sozusagen kommunizieren,
Manche sagen, bei der Schwerkraft ist genauso, da gibt's auch sowas wie ein Teilchen, also sowas wie ein Graviton und ähm,
und da da würde man dann diese ganzen geometrischen Beschreibungen nicht mal anwenden, also sich komplett davon entfernen.
Manche sagen das, okay, gut, aber das ist ja ähm auch jetzt erstmal, das sind jetzt auch sozusagen Thesen, die alle versuchen nochmal ein anderes Erklärungsmodell für die.
Das sind mathematische Beschreibungen derselben, derselben sozusagen physikalischen Phänomene.
Okay. Widmen wir uns mal der Gravitation nochmal, um einfach versuchen zum Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, was da eigentlich wirken kann. Also die Masse,
kommt in Raum.
Ist zumindest jetzt die Art und Weise, wie Einstein es beschrieben hat, mag andere Sichtweisen darauf geben, wo man vielleicht zum selben Ergebnis äh kommt. Aber das ist ja zumindest etwas,
funktioniert, was wir,
nachvollziehen können, was wir irgendwie berechnen können. Wir schicken irgendwelche Satelliten irgendwo hin, die fliegen durch die Gegend und dadurch, dass wir einfach diese Masse, die sich irgendwo bewegt zueinander in Beziehung setzen, eben auf Basis
äh Gleichung und Beschreibung kommen wir ja irgendwie an, ne? Wir haben Kometen besucht, et cetera, es funktioniert. Wir wissen, dass es irgendwie,
einer richtigen Lösung äh findet. Trotzdem scheint es nach wie vor ein totales Mysterium zu sein, was.
Eigentlich diese äh Schwerkraft letzten Endes ausmacht, was was wirklich der der tatsächliche physikalische Effekt ist, den die Masse auf diesen Raum hat.
Ja, also tiefgründig verstehen wir nicht, was die Schwerkraft ist. Zumindest verstehen wir sie nicht, wie wir sie, wie wir das mit den anderen äh ähm Kräften sozusagen in der Natur zu verstehen denken.
Mhm. Ist das nicht total frustrierend?
Ja, frustrierend, aber auch spannend. Also gleichzeitig.
Also man kann sozusagen Modelle aufstellen, um gewisse Phänomene auf gewissen Energieskalen zu beschreiben.
Wenn man damit zufrieden ist, dann kann man dann einfach das weitermachen. Aber wenn man dann grundlegend fundamental verstehen will,
woher das kommt und warum das so ist. Ähm da kommen dann halt diese ganzen Fragestellungen, die wir nicht beantworten können,
wir noch nicht wirklich sagen können, rassistisch Schwerkraft. Ist das nun ein Teilchen? Ist es nun die Krümmung? Das Raum-Zeit-Kontinuums, also was ist das?
Was denkst du denn, was das ist? Keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung. Also durch meine äh natürlich durch meinen Werdegang, auch durch meine Doktorarbeit ähm komme ich schon eher so äh von der Teilchenphysik Perspektive.
Wo ich dann halt die Schwerkraft als als Teilchen beschreiben würde.
Aber meine letzten Arbeiten waren auch sehr, sehr geometrisch, wo ich halt die Schwerkraft auch äh geometrisch beschrieben habe. Ähm das heißt also.
Du sparst dir die Meinung eigentlich komplett aus. Du versuchst dich dem Thema auf eine Art und Weise zu nähern, indem alles eigentlich möglich ist.
Ja, im Grunde ist alles ist alles möglich und man kann vielleicht sogar wagen über die Einsteinche Relativitätstheorie bisschen hinauszugehen, indem man vielleicht eine Theorie aufstellt, die sogar bisschen verallgemeinert ist.
Sagen, dass das jetzt so das Mysterium ist, die Schwerkraft.
Ja, ich denke schon, in der ähm in der modernen Physik äh ist die Schwerkraft schon ja das ja, das muss man knacken. Da gibt's Nobel.
Das muss man knacken. Da gibt's nur Weltpreise für.
Also eine eine sehr wichtige Frage ist halt, wie man sich Fwerkraft äh mit mit der Quantenmechanik halt in Verbindung bringt. Das heißt, wenn man auf sehr sehr sehr kleinen,
ähm Skalen gehen würde, super dumme Meere, noch kleinere, dann äh weiß man halt nicht,
wie man die einsteinche Theorie halt mit der Quantenmechanik in Verbindung bringen soll, aber auch wenn man auf sehr großen Skalen geht und versucht die die Bewegungen von Galaxien und Galaxienhaufen zu beschreiben.
Dann sieht man auch komische irgendwie Energie oder Materieformen, die man annehmen muss und das ist dann alles schon ziemlich rätselhaft.
Mhm. Das sind jetzt im Prinzip ja die zwei Orte, wo quasi die einsteinische Welt so ein bisschen an ihrer,
Grenzen zu kommen scheint. Hatten wir erst mal Newton
alles wunderbar funktioniert hat, aber in dem Moment, wo wir irgendwie den Planeten verlassen haben und größere Geschwindigkeiten und größere
Räume äh betrachtet haben
lief so langsam auseinander und äh man fragte sich, ob man nicht äh vielleicht noch irgendwelche kleinen Formelteilchen hinten ranhängen muss, damit's irgendwie passt. Dann kam irgendwie Einstein,
hat das im Prinzip aber getan, aber hat halt in dem Zuge auch noch eine komplett andere These,
geworfen, wie denn nun das eigentlich funktioniert und seine Idee der Raumzeit und der Krümmung des Raums konnte anhand
zahlreicher Experimente und Feststellung einfach auch belegt werden, dass auch seine Beschreibung passt. Nun,
aber eben vorne und hinten weitere Gedankenräume und physikalische Bereiche,
aus der Beobachtung jetzt schon klar ist,
Auch da funktioniert's nicht. Vielleicht kannst du mal kurz sagen was sind die Bereiche im Kleinen und was sind die Bereiche im Großen, wo wo sozusagen das Einsteinsche äh an seine Grenzen kommt und anfängt, vor sich hinzu scheitern.
Man kann sich ähm zwei Sachen anschauen, man stelle sich vor, man schießt irgendwelche Teilchen aufeinander mit mit sehr, sehr, sehr hohen Energien.
Halt aufeinander, so wie wir es bei LEC machen, aber wenn man das dann irgendwann auf so hohen Energieskaren machen würde, wo die Quanteneffekte der Schwerkraft selber sozusagen eine Rolle spielen würden. Da wissen wir nicht, wie die Theorie ähm,
funktionieren würde. Also die ist dann äh könnte sich so was vorstellen wie dass sie überall die regiert oder dass sie überhaupt keine Vorhersagen machen kann, ja?
Und auch wenn man zum Beispiel ähm die schwarzen Löcher beschreibt ähm oder oder das kosmologische den kosmologischen Ursprung, sowas wie Big Bang,
irgendwann weiß man, wenn man das dann zu weit treibt, dann kommt man auf irgendwelche Singularitäten und äh Singularität heißt nix anderes als,
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was da passiert, weil die Theorie ist nicht in der Lage,
oder dessen Gleichungen ist nicht in der Lage mir die physikalischen Phänomene zu beschreiben. Es es tauchen überall irgendwelche Unendlichkeiten auf oder ja es ist es hat null Aussagekraft. Ähm.
Mhm. Das heißt, die Formeln versagen.
Genau, die Formeln versagen und da kann man so, so ja, so weit pushen, wie man will, die Theorie will das nicht oder kann das einfach nicht. Und,
Auf der anderen Seite, wenn man dann halt auf großen Skalen geht und zum Beispiel Abstände zu den Galaxien oder Galaxienhaufen bestimmt, dann sieht man, dass die Galaxien sich immer schneller und immer schneller von uns wegbewegen.
Das Universum sich äh beschleunigt, expandiert,
Das kann man mit Hilfe der normalen Materie, die wir jetzt um uns herum kennen, können wir das auch nicht verstehen und beschreiben und müssen wir dann halt annehmen, dass so was wie eine dunkle Energie im Universum vorhanden sein muss,
die diese beschleunigte Expansion hervorruft.
Der anderen Seite, wenn man wiederum zum früheren Universum geht und denkt, aus diesem äh Big Bang Model ist irgendwie diese ganze Struktur entstanden, die wir jetzt beobachten.
Ähm und das sind halt damals sehr, sehr kleine ähm,
kleine Störfaktoren gewesen, also Störungen gewesen, Fluktuationen,
aus denen ist es unmöglich, mit unserer Standardtheorie zu erklären, wie diese ganze Struktur entstanden ist,
damit wir sie erklären können, müssen wir auch eine dunkle Materie hinzunehmen.
Wobei dunkle Energie und dunkle heißt sie, heißt sie, dass das äh etwas ist, von dem man weiß, dass es schwarz ist. So im Dunkel heißt einfach, wir wir haben keine Ahnung.
Absolut kein.
Es muss sich sozusagen dunkle Energie ist halt,
im Sinne von da ist eine, ich kann man sagen Kraft, also etwas, was sozusagen eine eine Kraft auswirkt auf die Materie, von der wir keine Ahnung haben,
was sie ist, woher sie kommt, wie sie sich manifestiert. Man weiß einfach überhaupt nix. Man weiß nur es müsste so etwas geben,
damit das, was wir sehen und messen können, auch Sinn macht äh im Kontext dessen, was wir derzeit wissen, wir alles zusammenhängt. Also das Universum wird auseinander geschleudert von etwas, erhält eine Beschleunigung.
Aber wir wissen nicht, was der Ursprung ist und nichts im einsteinschen äh Universum gibt uns irgendeinen Anhaltspunkt,
was die Quelle dessen sein könnte oder wodurch sich das in irgendeiner Form manifestiert, so dass halt wir feststellen so A das ganze Universum fliegt auseinander,
am Ende wird ja auch dadurch irgendwie alles auch nochmal aus also diese ganze,
des Universums ist ja nochmal eine zusätzliche Verzerrung des Raums. Mal ganz unabhängig von dieser Krümmung durch die Gravitation, also es ist sozusagen.
Es ist ja eine Energieform, also es Masse ist ja gleich Energie, also die Energie, die krümmt dann auch äh dieses Raum Zeitkonte, genau, zusätzlich.
Sozusagen. Also einerseits die Masse, die da ist, krümmt.
Und dann ist irgendeine Masse da oder eine Energie, wie auch immer die krümmt auch oder zerrt das alles auseinander konkret äh aber wir wissen nicht, was es ist.
Genau, wir wissen nicht, was das ist und ähm wir haben ähm wenn man innerhalb der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie,
bleiben würde, dann kann man einfach so 'ne konstante zu der Theorie dazu addieren. Die Theorie erlaubt das,
Das ist die Habelkonstantin, die kosmologische Konstante im Grunde. Ähm mit der kann man versuchen, diese beschleunigte Expansion zu beschreiben.
Weil sie schon äh wenn man halt so eine Konstante in seiner Theorie äh hinschreibt äh im Grunde gibt es dann am Ende irgend so eine Energieform, die einen negativen Druck hat,
und das ist auch etwas, was wir halt nicht kennen, irgendeinem Materieformen irgendwie, die negativen Druck hätte und ähm,
Aber damit könnten wir dann die beschleunigte Expansion beschreiben. Das Problem ist jetzt, wenn man dann verschiedene kosmologische Beobachtungen miteinander vergleicht, ähm die diesen Parameter halt messen, diese Habelkonstante zum Beispiel
dann gibt es Widersprüche. Also es sind diese von denen,
von denen die Leute reden. Also die Beobachtungen scheinen nicht auch äh zu übereinstimmen,
und ähm auf der einen Seite ist es halt schön, weil das halt einfaches Modell ist. Das ist das Standardmodell und ist relativ einfach,
aber es erklärt's nicht auf einer fundamentalen Ebene, es erklärt's nur Phänomenologisch sozusagen.
Aber selbst auf der phänomenologischen Ebene scheint sie doch irgendwie zu scheitern, weil halt verschiedene Beobachtungen verschiedene Werte liefern.
Also mit allen Worten, wir haben eigentlich keine Ahnung.
Ja, das kann man unterstreichen.
Mhm. Oh wow.
Okay, das sind also sozusagen unsere äh unsere Mysteriensammlung, ist ja auch eigentlich mal ganz gut, dass ein bisschen äh quantifizieren zu können so. Wir haben keine konkrete Vorstellung davon.
Wie Gravitation wirklich sich durch diesen Raum durchfrisst. Warum,
Masse oder Energie den Raum krümmt. Wir wissen nur, sie tut es. Das können wir nachvollziehen, das können wir berechnen, können wir irgendwie,
fliegen lassen und so weiter und GPS funktioniert und all diese ganzen Effekte können wir ausreichend berechnen, sodass die Dinge funktionieren, die wir derzeit so zum Funktionieren gebracht haben.
Nur erklären tut es das halt äh noch nicht. Wir haben keine wirkliche Vorstellung davon, was das bedeutet, dass der Raum sich krümmt. Wir wissen nur er krümmt sich, aber wir wissen nicht, wodurch,
Wirklich letzten Endes, also was fundamental der Vorgang ist, der sich dort
abspielt, um diesen Effekt zu erzielen. Genauso wenig wissen wir es mit dem Herausschleudern der Expansion des gesamten Universums, die ja auch nicht nur,
da ist, sondern sich ja auch immer weiter,
beschleunigt, also wird ja auch immer schneller sozusagen, also das Ganze uns wird ja eigentlich das Universum gerade entzogen. Ne, also es ist ja irgendwann sehen wir ja gar nichts mehr, weil die Dinge so weit weg sind,
Das ist Licht, sich eigentlich von uns schneller, also es wird von von uns wegexpandiert, schneller, als es zu uns zurückkehren kann.
Also wir haben so eine Art Unbeobachtbaren Raum, von dem wissen wir ja ohnehin schon, dass er da ist. Es gibt Objekte, die sind einfach,
schneller unterwegs, also schnell entfernen sich, schneller von uns als sich Licht uns annähern kann und das wird aber immer noch schlimmer, das heißt Dinge, die wir jetzt vielleicht noch sehen können, von denen wissen wir jetzt schon, dass wir sie irgendwann nicht mehr sehen können.
Eine furchtbare Vorstellung oder? Also es ist ja totale Katastrophe.
Und dann mit der dunklen Materie wiederum wissen wir auch bei Sachen, die wir beobachten können,
die ganze Einscheinsche äh Formelsammlung auch nicht ausreicht, um zu beschreiben, was wir konkret sehen können. Das Beispiel war die Bewegung von,
Galaxien, die irgendwie, wenn man halt mit unserem Formelwerk äh rangeht und sagt, okay, wir sehen so und so viel Materie, weil so und so viel Licht und,
zumindest eine Vorstellung oder meine Vorstellung davon zu haben, was da eigentlich an Materie drin ist, das.
Aber nicht so drehen könnte, wie wir's beobachten, also passt das irgendwie auch nicht. Also wir wissen eigentlich gar nix.
Ja also ähm wie gesagt, wenn man dann halt ähm auf größeren und größeren Entfernungen geht, wenn man wenn wir versuchen unseren Horizont bisschen zu erweitern, dann,
halt diese ganzen rätselhaften Fragen auch dazu.
Jetzt würde mich mal interessieren, jetzt gibt's ja verschiedenste Kandidaten und Vorschläge und Ideen ähm,
was, wie man das jetzt sozusagen vereinigen könnte oder wie man Erklärungen finden könnte,
String-Theorie, keine Ahnung, was müsste man jetzt hier alles aufzählen? Was sind das für Gedankenexperimente, was,
deiner Meinung nach da auch äh genug Fleisch, um vielleicht noch mal was äh zu werden? Wie wie wie denkst du über dieses Problem nach und vor allem
uns vielleicht mal so ein bisschen mitnehmen, wie man auch darüber nachdenkt, also was hätte da überhaupt gar keinen Ansatz nachzuvollziehen,
wie man da versucht eine Lösung zu finden.
Ja, also ich denke ähm ein eine gute ja.
Vorangehensweise wäre zum Beispiel halt die ganzen Annahmen nochmal durchzugehen die die allgemeine Relativitätstheorie ausmachen, also die,
grundlegenden Eigenschaften sozusagen? Was sind die die ganzen Annahmen?
Versuchen, diese Annahmen, Stück für Stück so bisschen zu lockern oder zu aufzugeben und dann zu studieren, was hat das dann für Konsequenzen?
Also so was zum Beispiel könnte man machen. Ähm das hat auch den Vorteil, dass man eigentlich die allgemeine Relativitätstheorie,
immer besser und immer besser zu zu verstehen scheint oder oder dass man dann halt auch.
Sie vielleicht äh mehr und mehr wertschätzt, weil die Dinge sich dann sehr schnell für komplizieren.
Eine Idee in der Kosmologie zumindest ist es ähm zu sagen, okay ähm anstatt anzunehmen, dass da so was wie eine dunkle Materie oder dunkle Energie vorhanden ist. Vielleicht muss man die Theorie selber, also die Formeln selber,
halt erweitern und ändern, sodass man am Ende halt diese zusätzliche Energie- und Materieformen nicht mehr haben müsste.
Um die Beobachtungen beschreiben zu können. Ähm das sind dann die verallgemeinerungen der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie.
Man kann das ähm man kann das machen, indem man ähm zum Beispiel zusätzliche,
Felder in die Theorie hineinführt, also zusätzliche äh,
In der Taschensprache würde das sagen äh zusätzliche Teilchen sozusagen, die die Schwerkraft beschreiben würde.
Man könnte aber auch innerhalb der Geometrie halt ähm von unterschiedlichen geometrischen Eigenschaften starten und versuchen, diese zu verallgemeinern.
Und ich denke mal, man müsste dann halt systematisch vorgehen und und versuchen, ganz verschiedene, viele ähm,
Richtungen halt auszuprobieren und zu gucken, dann stimmen diese dann mit den Beobachtungen besser überein? Oder werden sie sofort ähm,
sofort aus dem Spiel. Genau, das ist zum Beispiel ein Teil unserer unserer Forschung in der Gruppe,
wo wir genau diese Fragen uns stellen und Theorien aufstellen und diese dann halt auch mit den Beobachtungen vergleichen.
Was ist da so bisher rausgekommen? Ich meine, ihr seid ja nicht die einzigen, die daran arbeiten und es gibt ja.
Genau, ganz viele.
Genannt. Es gibt ja, gibt ja schon so verschiedene Ansätze. Hat da irgendwas schon mal für besondere Aufmerksamkeit gesorgt und ist irgendwas schon widerlegt? Was was sind so diese Ansätze, die es da bisher gegeben hat, das alles zu.
Ja, so es gab schon äh ein paar Theorien, die für eine gewisse Zeit bisschen Unruhe hervorgerufen haben, beziehungsweise wo wo halt mehrere Gruppen gleichzeitig da dran gearbeitet haben und man merkt es dann meistens halt, dass die,
die Zitierungen halt äh äh ziemlich hoch gehen. Ähm ähm eine Sache war, ähm wenn man annehmt, dass dass das Graviton Teilchen,
nicht masselos wäre, sondern wenn es Masse hätte, das wäre dann halt die massive Schwerkraft,
Das war ein Thema, was was meine Doktormutter sozusagen äh woran sie gearbeitet hat und wodurch ich durch sie so ein bisschen äh beeinflusst beeinflusst worden bin.
Ich selber habe ähm angenommen, dass da ähm ein ein Teilchen äh vorhanden wäre, was sich so ähnlich verhält wie ein Foto.
Es hat sehr, sehr ähnliche Eigenschaften wie wie ein Foto. Das ist ein Vektorfeld, nennt man das,
in unserem äh in unserer Community und und dadurch kann man auch ähm sehr einfach ähm diese beschleunigte Expansionen äh hervorrufen.
Ähm dann genau ähm,
momentan äh gibt's auch diese diese Theorie ähm an der wir auch arbeiten, dass man dann sagt ähm die Schwerkraft nicht ist nicht an,
wegen der Krümmung des Raumzeitkontinums, sondern ist die nichtmetrige Eigenschaft.
Des Raumzeitkontinums und mit dieser nichtmetrik Eigenschaft kann man auch versuchen, die Beobachtungen zu beschreiben.
Was heißt nicht Metrigeigenschaft?
Ja, das für mich dann schon schwierig, das für für eine Laie zu beschreiben.
Weil es leider nicht diese Hilfsmittel gibt ähm mit der Krümmung von diesem Trampolin, oder?
Eigentlich auch falsch ist, ist ja nicht bar, wirklich wahrhaftig so. Ähm aber zum Beispiel, wenn man so was wie nichtmetrik ähm,
in der Raum Zeit hätte, dann würden sich die Längen äh Wahrnehmungen sich ändern, also die die Längen des der der Vektorfelder würden sich ähm anpassen oder ändern.
Also man hat sozusagen kein einheitliches Koordinatensystem innerhalb dieser Betrachtungsgröße.
Man kann schon Konnatensystem äh auch einbauen, aber ähm,
Genau, man kann sozusagen ähm also in der in der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie ähm gibt es, ähm wenn man zum Beispiel einen einen ein Objekt hat, das irgendwie eine gewisse Länge hat,
Wenn man das jetzt einfach auf einer geraden Linie äh in diesem Gravitationsfeld äh hätte und ohne dass da irgendwelche Verzerrungen,
stattfinden, dann würde sich diese Länge gar nicht ändern.
Das wäre zum Beispiel in äh in einer Geometrie, wo man diese nichtmetrike Eigenschaft äh hätte, wäre das dann anders. Die Länge dieses Objekts würde sich dann ändern.
Aber es ist schwer ähm es ist schwer, dass irgendwie ähm verbildlichen, weil das halt mathematische,
Beschreibungen sind. Genauso wie die also das ist auch irgendwie eine Verdrehung äh der Raumzeit.
Und wie soll man sich jetzt eine Fettdrehung der Raumzeit vorstellen? Es ist halt.
Also ich meine, wenn wenn ihr in der Lage seid, euch das vorzustellen, dann ist ja schon mal eine ganze Menge äh geholfen, aber das reicht mir eigentlich auch. Ich will wollte ja nur verstehen, wie so die Ansätze sind. Also man geht wirklich mathematisch.
Die Sache äh heran. So und das vielleicht auch erstmal gar nicht mit einer klaren,
Visionen, was so die Lösung sein kann, sondern man probiert herum und schaut, ob man überhaupt einen mathematischen Ansatz findet, sodass,
alles was bisher funktioniert, auch noch mit dieser Methode funktioniert. Und danach macht man sich vielleicht erst einen Reim drauf, warum denn das jetzt passen könnte. Also ist ein bisschen wie so ein Puzzle lösen, wo man nicht genau weiß, wo man das Puzzlesteinchen jetzt
hintot, sagen wir mal, probiert so ein bisschen aus irgendwie ah hier die Form, nee da ist vielleicht dann doch irgendwie an einer anderen äh Stelle, damit sich letzten Endes ein Gesamtbild daraus äh ergibt
Aber was ist so mit,
wie das Trink Theorie et cetera, was was ist das für ein Beitrag, um um dieses diese Vereinheitlichung der Systeme herbeizuführen?
Ja, also String-Theorie, wie gesagt, ist auch so eine eine mathematische Beschreibung, ähm wie man versuchen könnte, die Schwerkraft, mit ähm der Quantenmechanik halt in Verbindung zu bringen. Also das wäre so was wie ein Kandidat für Quantengravity.
Das einzige Problem ist dort ähm es findet halt auf so hohen Energien statt.
Oder basiert sich diese Theorie auf Skalen, dass man das.
Vorhersagen nicht direkt verifizieren oder kann mit Experimenten, die wir zum Beispiel halt hier machen, also zum Beispiel mit den Beschleunigeranlagen am am Zähnen, das können wir nie erreichen.
Um um solche Energieskalen zu erreichen, wo man dann Stringy-Effekte für anfangen würde zu beobachten.
Aber ich bin da jetzt nicht so pessimistisch und ich bin der Meinung, dass da die Kosmologie vielleicht bisschen zu Hilfe kommt, weil die Kosmologie ist ja,
nicht nur was uns um uns herum jetzt hier passiert, sondern die komplette Entstehung und Entwicklung.
Seit dem Ursprung sozusagen und wenn man sehr sehr zurück also wenn man annimmt dass,
ähm dass da halt diese Expansion des Universum stattfindet, was wir hier beobachten und wenn man dann jetzt zurückgeht.
Müsste es ja früher ähm komprimiert sein, also viel kleiner gewesen sein und und je früher man geht, umso heißer müsste es dann gewesen sein und das ist ja diese Hot Big Bang.
Irgendwann war es alles so energetisch, dass man dann wiederum halt eine indirekte Art und Weise.
Hoch Energiephysikphänomene zu zu beobachten,
Das würde man dann halt anhand von kosmologischen Beobachtungen über sehr, sehr lange Zeit sich angesammelten ähm indirekten Effekte halt versuchen zu zu beobachten.
Beispiel wenn man annimmt, dass diese beschleunigte Expansion durch die kosmologische Konstante irgendwie entsteht, was man ja zu der einsteinste Theorie dazunehmen kann, ist es sehr, sehr schwierig von der String-Theorie, eine kosmologische Konstante herzu,
kriegen, herzubasten.
Und äh wenn wir sage ich mal irgendwann mit unseren äh Beobachtungen so genau sein können, dass wir die kosmologische Konstante entweder bestätigen oder ausschließen können,
Dann wäre das ein bisschen so was wie eine indirekte Untersuchung des Trinktheorie selber,
sozusagen wozu ist diese Quanten-Theorie in der Lage um meine kosmologische Beobachtungen,
zu beschreiben oder ob sie dann überhaupt vielleicht sogar in in Widerspruch ist zu den kosmologischen Beobachtungen.
Wie unabhängig es jetzt diese theoretische Forschung, dieses dieses mathematische und teilweise sicherlich auch,
philosophische Suchen nach einer Lösung. Das so würde ich's ja mal beschreiben. Inwiefern ist das abhängig von weiteren,
Experimentellen Erkenntnissen. Ich denke jetzt natürlich vor allem an das Jabs Web Teleskop, was äh,
in den letzten Monaten ja sehr erfolgreich gestartet äh entfaltet und äh zu diesem Zeitpunkt. Wir nehmen jetzt äh hier auf im äh Mitte April zwanzig zweiundzwanzig. Äh wir wissen
alles funktioniert sehr gut. Also äh ähm am Maximum dessen, was man hätte erwarten
können, also es kündigt sich an, dass wir im Prinzip diesen die alte Zeit des Universums, also das sehr weite Schauen in das Universum, dass das jetzt demnächst,
interessante Ergebnisse liefern könnte. Erwartest du dir da neues Futter, auch für diese theoretische Suche nach Lösung oder ist es davon weitgehend entkoppelt.
Also auf jeden Fall werden wir äh,
mehrere neue Satelliten haben, neue Daten, die zur Verfügung stehen werden. Und ein Problem wird sein, dass da so viel zu ein sehr komplexer Datensatz vorhanden sein wird und auch noch so groß, dass man vielleicht.
Als Mensch nicht in der Lage sein wird diese Datenmenge zu bewerten und ähm ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass so was wie alte Fischschule Intelligence halt immer mehr und immer mehr eine Rolle spielen wird,
einfach diese Daten auszuwerten und gewisse physikalische halt ähm Eigenschaften aus den Daten herauszufiltern.
Ähm ein anderes Problem ist halt, dass ähm dass es jetzt nicht so wie damals so einsteiniger Zeit wo die Theorie und die Experimente schon so ein bisschen Hand in Hand äh gingen.
Vielleicht waren sogar die Theorien den Beobachtungen ein bisschen voraus und momentan ist eher so das Gegenteil.
Die Experimente sind äh sind ziemlich voraus und aber wir haben das theoretische Verständnis noch nicht so ganz entwickelt.
Genau und da werden dann wahrscheinlich schon wieder sehr, sehr ähm ja,
Ansätze gebraucht, die wahrscheinlich sehr radikal sind, wo man auch halt stark pushen muss, dass sowohl Theorie als auch Experimente bisschen bisschen enger,
zusammengehen und das ist auch eine der Gründe, warum wir halt in unserer Gruppe versuchen,
Nicht nur theoretisch unterwegs zu sein, sondern auch halt die Beobachtungen ähm in Betracht zu zählen.
Was brauchst du denn jetzt für den großen Durchbruch? Äh brauchen wir eher noch mal so ein Wunderkind, was irgendwie zehn Jahre äh im Café sitzt und dann äh ich weiß, diesen Heureka im Moment hat's nicht gegeben, aber sozusagen äh da äh,
jemand dadurch hervorstechen wird,
einfach ganz anders über etwas nachgedacht zu haben oder ist die Wissenschaft die theoretische Physik mittlerweile auch mehr so als so ein gesamter äh Organismus weltweit und trägt sich permanent neue Ideen zu?
Greift man vieles auf oder versucht man mehr seinen eigenen Weg zuzugehen? Wie geht's dir da.
Ja, also ich glaube, momentan ist es schon so, dass man einen sehr, sehr spezialisiertes Wissen sich aneignet und,
man forscht, umso mehr man in diese Richtung reinrutscht,
Äh wie gesagt, damals 19zehn, neunzehnhundertfünf, was auch immer, da da wusste man auch nicht noch nicht so viel über die Physik und vielleicht konnte man mit zwei, drei Büchern.
Schon fast das gesamte Wissen sich aneignen.
Aber heutzutage jetzt selbst innerhalb der theoretischen Physik, selbst innerhalb der Schwerkraft gibt es so viele ähm subklassen sozusagen subspezialisierte Forschungsgebiete,
wo man dann sehr viel Wissen innerhalb dieses spezialisierten Richtung halt äh herauskriegt,
aber dann das Gesamtbild geht manchmal so bisschen verloren oder? Und das ist dann halt sehr schwierig,
Ich glaube, früher konnten sie zum Beispiel sogar Physik und Chemie und alles
zusammen machen und und die Theoretiker haben sogar Experimente gemacht, aber jetzt werden wir eher so immer mehr und mehr so bisschen fast wie Fachidioten. Wir wissen dann halt sehr, sehr viel über unser spezielles äh.
Ähm ja unseren unseren Fachgebiet aber nicht so.
Schwierig das Große und Ganze noch im Blick zu behalten,
so viel Wissen über einen Spezialbereich erstmal ansammeln muss, um das überhaupt zu verstehen. Kann ich gut nachvollziehen. Ist es vielleicht eine denkbare,
Zukunft, dass wir dann tatsächlich durch solche trainierten Algorithmen und solche Erkenntnis
orientierten äh Algorithmen in irgendeiner Form nach der oder bestimmten Lösung forschen könnten, also es ist vorstellbar
man quasi ein System programmiert, was dieses Wissen und diese Ideen in sich versucht aufzunehmen und.
Zuwegen und nach Lösungen zu finden. Das klingt klingt sehr nach Science-Fiction.
Ja, also wahrscheinlich, es kann durchaus sein, dass man vielleicht eine wirklich wahren Durchbruch hat, nur wenn man dann,
dieses sehr spezielle Wissen aus seinem sehr speziellen Fachgebiet mit einem anderen verbinden muss, was vielleicht sehr weit weg ist und wir einfach nicht die menschliche Kapazität dazu haben. Und wenn diese gelernte Algorithmen dazu in der Lage wären.
Dann könnten Sie das vielleicht knacken oder? Also dass Sie das dann halt äh doch herauskriegen könnten. Aber ich weiß nicht, also ich bin da eher,
optimistisch irgendwie unterwegs. Es kann auch sein, dass wir Stück für Stück gewisse Dinge halt ähm da herausfinden werden, wodurch wir dann ganz neue Wege ähm,
finden werden und dass wir dann vielleicht jetzt ähm auf einmal vielleicht möglich wird, auf andere Galaxien zu reisen und und andere Formen von Beobachtungen zu machen und so weiter.
Du bist zuversichtlich, dass eine Lösung noch gefunden wird.
Ich bin zuversichtlich zumindest, dass wir unsere Grenzen schon sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr stark ähm pushen werden,
und dass wir zwar das jetzt so machen und fast so sich so anfühlt, als ob wir so in der Dunkelheit blind schwimmen,
dass wir vielleicht gewollt oder ungewollt auf irgendwelche Sachen äh stoßen werden, was uns dann ganz großen Schritt nach vorne bringen wird.
Mhm und das ist ja dann die Grundlagenforschung oder? Dass man dann äh halt klein nach vorne so kleine Schritte nach vorne macht, indem man halt viele Sachen vielleicht ausschließt,
aber als Bonuspunkt andere Sachen entdeckt, die man vielleicht nicht mal geplant hat, ja.
Ja das äh noch so nebenbei. Trotzdem ist es so ein bisschen man tastet im dunklen Raum und sucht nach dem Lichtschalter, aber es kann ja auch sein, dass man in morgen schon äh findet und dann äh wird alles klar.
Ja schön. Das heißt, es geht voran. Vielleicht noch so zum Schluss noch mal so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, weil es gibt ja immer so diese These,
Hm ja seit Einstein ist ja eigentlich nix mehr passiert so.
Okay.
Ich sehe schon, die teils dieser Auffassung äh nicht.
Die Stringtheoretiker sind wahrscheinlich der anderer Meinung.
Okay, gut, aber jetzt nur mal so gefühlt ähm.
Wie empfindest du die Beschleunigung im Erkenntnisgewinn, was jetzt so diese großen Theorien, das Gesamtverständnis von allem betrifft? Wie.
Sind wir da? Hat sich da was verlangsamt oder
nimmt die Geschwindigkeit äh vielleicht die ganze Zeit zu, also verhält sich sozusagen unser Erkenntnisgewinn, gerade so wie die äh Universumsexpansion oder äh
drehen wir uns ein bisschen im im Kreis oder macht's zumindest derzeit den Eindruck, wenn man jetzt mal so von Dekade zu Dekade geht, ist der Erkenntnisgewinn konstant, ist ja irgendwie,
kaum vorhanden, expandiert er. Was ist so deine Wahrnehmung, wie unser Weltwissen sich verändert.
Ja, also ich würde schon sagen, dass wir ähm dass wir schon sehr viel Wissen generieren. Ähm ich habe ja gesagt, immer immer spezielles Wissen.
Auf der anderen Seite ist das System auch so aufgebaut, dass man nicht auf die Art und Weise forschen kann, wie man's vielleicht halt zu einsteiniger Zeit gemacht hat. Also ich glaube nicht, dass Einstein irgendwie.
Diesen Druck hatte, oh, als Postdruck muss man dann halt äh sehr schnell Wissen generieren und und dies und jenes publizieren und.
Und schnell vorankommen und und ich glaube, da müsste man vielleicht manchmal auch bisschen bremsen und manchmal vielleicht sogar einen Schritt zurückgehen.
Und noch mal diese ganz fundamentalen Annahmen in Frage stellen und und eventuell vielleicht sogar wagen, diese aufzugeben oder komplett neue anzunehmen.
Die Zwischenergebnisse der letzten Jahrzehnte sozusagen. Also so wenn man jetzt so was was für meinen verstanden zu haben,
in den 20ern, in den 30ern, in den 40ern, so bis heute. Ist das irgendwie eine Kurve, die ansteigt? Äh wird.
Ja total, also es ist,
Das ist fast wie eine ja eine exponentielle Beschleunigung und ähm ich würde sogar sagen selbst innerhalb der Schwerkraft jetzt ähm,
die ganzen neuen Satelliten wie und auch andere ähm jetzt auch mit den Gravitationswellen ähm wir haben jetzt,
so viel mehr neue Beobachtungsmöglichkeiten
und äh und allein jetzt von diesem Leigovigo ähm Beobachtungen haben wir schon so viel Wissen generiert. Also ähm ich würde schon sagen, das ist wirklich so eine.
Exponentielle Entwicklung des Wissens ist.
Was jetzt die Beobachtung betrifft und was man aber die Theorie, die muss dem sozusagen jetzt noch hinterher laufen.
Die Theorie läuft momentan etwas hinterher, ja.
Ihr seid dran.
Aber wir sind dran, ja. Und hoffentlich nicht sehr weit weg.
Super, Lavinia, vielen, vielen Dank für die Ausführung,
Ja? Unser Versuch hier mal ein bisschen aufzuräumen, was äh eigentlich die theoretische Physik äh gerade äh versucht alles zu verstehen und schon verstanden hat.
Das war's. Die hundertste Folge von äh Raumzeit. Ähm vielen Dank davinia.
Bald geht's wieder weiter.